hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the norway ukraine friendly
solidarity match uh the game you guys
requested as soon as it finished it's
yuri kosovo versus magnus carlsen uh the
last time two of them faced off against
each other was i believe in the uh
feeder fitted grants with that magnus
one and now kuzubov has a chance to
well retaliate with the white pieces and
this is uh one game that you will
thoroughly enjoy so let's dive straight
into it and see if norway can strike
back against ukraine uh so kuzubov opens
with d4 we have d5 by magnus c4 uh c6
and now e3 if you guys remember from the
previous video uh ukraine won both uh
match one and match two this is now a
game from match three uh first match was
one two and a half one and a half and
the second match three to one for
ukraine so now this is the third match
we have bishop to f5 and now knight to
c3 we have e6 and now a move no one ever
plays uh in this position except kuzubov
he has played it on two occasions apart
from this one and uh it's uh it's a very
tricky one uh so magnus goes knight to
f6 knight back to g3 uh attacking the
bishop here bishop g6 and now bishop to
d3 we have knight beat to d7 by magnus
castles and the bishop to d6 so ready to
castle king side rook to e1 and the
position has been reached before and it
was in the game jordan fun for us versus
yuri kuzubov where castles was played
but here magnus plays bishop captures on
d3 and it is now as of move 9 that we
have a completely new game so uh yuri
captures on d3 we have queen to a5 uh
developing the queen now saying maybe i
will castle queen side who knows c
captures on d5 c captures and the bishop
to d2 threatening some nasty discoveries
magnus decides to castle king side and
now you don't really have all that many
good discoveries but you do have knight
b5 and this is what you replace attacks
the queen
and you have to keep an eye on the
bishop the bishop on d6 is hanging so
queen to a6 guarding the bishop and now
a4
so very very a good position for for
yuri but also for magnus there's no
problem here for black so rook f the c8
and now f3 preparing to strike in the
center with e4 and e5 but also taking
away some very important squares from
the knight on f6 uh we have b6 uh giving
the queen the b7 square to retreat if
needed and now comes ponta e4 now with
the very unpleasant threat of e5 so
bishop back to f8 and now point the e5
grabbing more space here magnus goes
knight to e8 and now f4 so now you can
see that kuzubov is controlling
a lot more space
but if uh played correctly should not be
a problem uh we have g6 and now h4 he
wants to open up uh
magnus's position on the king side as
all of his uh forces are on the queen
side the queen not doing all that much
on a6 the rook on a8 okay the rook on c8
is on a nice open c file
but that's pretty much it we have queen
to b7 magnus will try to get the queen
back into the game now comes h5
we have a6 chasing the night away and
you don't have any good in between moves
so knight back to c3 knight the g7
trying to force uh uh yuri to advance
that pawn to h6 but this is exactly what
he does it's actually very good and now
the problem is if you go knight to f5
we're just gonna capture it and now if
you play e captures on f5 there's g4 and
the black's position will slowly uh fall
apart all of black's forces are still on
the queen side so instead after h6
magnus goes knight back to e8
but there is a problem now because white
has a beautiful move that he can use the
breakthrough in the position and i'm
sure you guys see it without even
pausing the video and that move of
course is pawn to f5 now it seems silly
as the pawn is the
df5 square is guarded twice by both the
e and the g pawn uh but if it works it
works so here magnus plays e captures an
f5 and now of course knight captures an
f5 we will give up the knight
to open up the black king's position and
now you can see that the pawn being on
h6 the rooks are very easy easily
transferable to the attack uh it's not
going to be easy to defend this for
magnus so g captures an f5 queen
captures on f5 and then now rook to c6
we have to be ready to block with rook
to g6 so rook to f1 attacking the f7
pawn and not knight to b8 uh defending
the f7 pawn with the queen but still
look at those uh
that queen side this is uh very very
ugly knight captures on d5 introducing
the knight into the attack as well and
now magnus plays rook to g6 so there
really is no good move for magnus here
but rook to g6 seems to be the most
resilient one as the game will show
but it's also a completely losing idea
so feel free to pause the video and try
and win the game for yuri here while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
incredibly difficult idea at the spot
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is ponte e6 uh and
this solves pretty much everything now
our knight is hanging uh and we have to
deal with this uh yori decided to play
knight to f4 but it is actually pawn to
e6 that wins and again it looks very odd
but if pawn captures then we just play
queen captures an f8 checkmate uh if
rook captures then it's a bit more
tricky but rook 8 to e1 it's a very very
silent move and not one that
you know you can spot easily but if
let's say rook calculus rook captures
now your knight here is hanging and if
knight to d7 keep an eye on your knight
now you play knight to e7 check bishop
captures and the rook captures and now
f7 is hanging and also the the knight on
d7 is hanging and uh across its position
just falls apart so the only thing you
have after e6 is basically f6 uh but not
just e7 and this is just beautiful
bishop captures on e7 knight captures
with czech queen captures and now queen
d5 check we pick up the rook on a8 and
that's it we are simply up too much
material so uh while e6 here was winning
on the spot knight the f4 was played in
the game as this is rapid uh and now
magnus plays bishop captures an h6 he
decides to give up the rook to activate
his pieces but also the bishop on d2
would hang if you capture the rook
however here still capturing with the
rook was the way to go and now if e6
we're just going to play rook to f6
challenge the queen and this is how
black survives however after knight to
f4
we have bishop captures on h6 but now
just knight captures on g6 h captures on
g6 attacking the queen and the bishop
but the queen does not go back to help
out with the defense of the bishop uh
rather queen to g4 and interestingly
this is the only winning move in the
position so there's really nothing
better than to capture the bishop here
and now comes e6 uh we completely bust
open uh the king's side f6 we have a
queen captures on g6 knight to g7 if you
block with queen to g7 then the knight
just hangs so we have to block with the
knight and now our good friend the queen
side rook joins the attack rook to a3
and now how do you uh how do you uh play
this well queen to d5 was played by
magnus it's a nice centralizing move
going after that d4 pawn with check
but now it's uh well it's very very
unfortunate for magnus that
yuri has a forced mate in nine so it's a
very very tricky to spot it and it might
not be all that easy to visualize but
just for practice feel free to pause the
video and try to spot this uh you know
incredible mate while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on being able to
solve
absolutely everything and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
queen f7 check i'm sure everyone picked
up on this one king h7 rook the h3 with
check bishop to h6 and now the move you
had this spot
is rook captures an h6 in the actual
game queen captures an f6 was played but
magnus is lost regardless of what yuri
plays pretty much but just to show you
the brilliancy rook captures an h6 king
captures now rook captures on f6 king h7
queen the g6 with check king the g8 and
now rook to f8 check so we give up both
rooks king captures and now of course
queen to f7 will be checkmate so it's a
rapid game of course you don't have all
the time in the world to
find such finesses so in the game queen
captures and f6 was played but there is
no recovering from this knight stay h5
okay you survive a little bit longer but
now queen f7 check knight back to g7
rook to f6 again rook captures an h6 is
always an idea but okay rook to f6 queen
captures on d4 with check king to h1 now
queen d1 check king h2 and here after
queen to d6 check uh yuri played rook to
g3 and he was in this position on move
41 that magnus calls and resigned in the
game and yet another brilliant victory
not just for uh yuri kuzubu but also for
the team ukraine uh who defeated uh
team norway again uh
two and a half to one and a half and in
the r or rather it was two and a half to
one and a half in round three and round
four ended again by ukraine winning at
uh three to one so uh ukraine completely
uh uh crushes norway in this match
uh um uh games one and three were two
and a half one and a half and games two
and four were three to one so uh
complete annihilation and i might also
show a game from round four as uh you
guys have already requested that one uh
so stay tuned for that so brilliant
brilliant game and it really shows you
how uh this um well uh idea that is very
very rarely played just knight g to e2
can throw even uh someone like like
magnus off guard and you know uh force
him into a completely passive position
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it again uh a big
congratulations to yuri on his amazing
victory against the world champion uh i
would like to thank usfdfri nicholas
padau andrew dabrovsky kirsten lemmons
and the guy le fleur lux course for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day